talk radio host and conspiracy theorist
alex jones has been ordered to pay more
than four million dollars to the parents
of a six-year-old boy who was killed in
the sandy hook massacre this follows the
dramatic trial where jones admitted that
the massacre happened after years of
telling his listeners it didn't as nancy
chen reports that's only part of what he
may eventually have to pay
i will accept this as a verdict of the
jury marking the first time alex jones
will be held financially responsible for
repeatedly claiming the 2012 sandy hook
shooting was a hoax the radio show host
must pay more than 4 million dollars to
neil heslin and scarlett lewis the
parents of jesse lewis a six-year-old
who died in the massacre jesse was real
i am a real mom the verdict comes after
the parents this week recounted years of
harassment from jones followers i can't
even
the describe nine and a half years of
the living hell
that i and others have had endure in
jones own testimony wednesday he
conceded under oath the shooting
actually happened it's 100
and was caught off guard when lawyers
for the family said jones's attorneys
had mistakenly shared years worth of his
texts that showed he withheld evidence
everybody was mistaken i was mistaken
but you've got the messages right there
after the verdict jones released a video
claiming the reduced amount as a victory
what i did to those families was wrong
but i didn't do it on purpose but the
family's lawyer said this was only part
of what jones will have to pay as the
jury still has to decide on punitive
damages it's a win for the sandy hook
families and it's a win for truth and
justice civil rights attorney alexander
tobbs said this sets a precedent for
other cases against jones it sends a
message that there is a cost there is a
price to lying about people in the
public sphere
and the jury will return today to hear
evidence about jones finances for its
decision on any punitive damages due to
heslin and lewis jones does face more
lawsuits in texas and connecticut for
his false claims and this jury's award
puts at a marker in those cases
it's an intense case and it's something
that everyone has an opinion on that's
for sure we will be watching see more
thank you nancy